I know you're in the middle of filming
season two uh how is filming been going
great it's going great I can't wait to
till I can actually talk about it and
and
uh people can see what we're what we're
doing uh it's but it's it's really fun
it's really really cool you got to be
part of Madam Webb which is your entry
into into Sony's Marvel World
um was that something you were looking
for and what can you tease about it you
know I wasn't I I actually didn't think
I was gonna work
um over the summer uh before we started
Severance up again because we started in
October and I thought I I I wasn't
planning on working at all and before
then
and then this came up and
um and I I I couldn't resist it's really
it's really cool um it's a really fun uh
world and and a great role and uh but I
can't really say that much uh about it
other than
um it's cool and fun which I'm sure
you're so sick of hearing from people